we have exclusive new information on the
largest welfare scandal in Mississippi
history CBS News has obtained never
before seen evidence linking that effort
to retired NFL superstar Brett Favre's
pet projects Omar via Franca has the
story
this is a game changer a new concussion
drug backed by NFL legend Brett Favre
needed financing so he turned to his
home state of Mississippi the poorest in
the nation the pitch was made in 2019 at
Farr's home to the former head of the
state's Human Services and Nancy new the
founder of a non-profit that distributed
welfare funds in the state in a document
obtained exclusively by CBS News the
drug company previcus asked for nearly 2
million from the division of Human
Services in the state of Mississippi
they struck this agreement in exchange
for funding the drug would be made and
tested in Mississippi
former Federal prosecutor Brad pygut
investigated the transactions for the
state both Federal and Mississippi Law
required 100 of that money to go only to
the alleviation of poverty within
Mississippi court documents show
predicus was sent 1.5 million dollars
with farv's business associate later
asking for the rest we would love 784k
he wrote with a smiley face emoji in a
text message obtained by CBS news new
responded we can send 400k today adding
I will need to let Brett know that we
will need to pull this from what we were
hoping to help with on other activities
she has since pleaded guilty for helping
funnel millions in welfare money for a
volleyball center at farv's alma mater
Eric hirschman Brett Favre's attorney
insists his client didn't know the
grants were coming from welfare funds
and that farv didn't personally receive
any of the money paid to previcus we
have documents that show Mr farv and his
business partner asking roughly two
million dollars from the state for
prefaces why were they asking the state
for money well to be clear I think
Brett's job was to make the
introductions but keeping this in mind
this is the Mississippi Department of
Human Services this is a thing if the
drug is successful well obviously
benefit people throughout the country so
they were discussing a state Grant no
one ever said that the Mississippi Grant
funds were coming from a federal entity
that limited the welfare funds well
you're almost making them sound like a
patsy like he was set up nobody's a
patsy except no one told him you want
the outside quarterback to look at and
say wait a minute let me challenge the
entire State as to what they do with
their own funds this is not philanthropy
it's not a passive investor he and
provided the director of the Mississippi
Department of Human Services into his
house to receive the sales pitch farv
has not been charged with any crime the
state of Mississippi is suing to get
back to 2.1 million dollars from the
drug company and its Affiliates last
month the company announced they had
completed the first round of clinical
trials in Australia
Omar villafranca CBS News Dallas